hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update next month microsoft is
going to be introducing some new
features for their Xbox one console the
most important part of this june system
update is the long awaited arrival of
external storage drives must be at least
256 gigabytes and use USB 3.4 matted as
well which the xbox one can do for you
you'll be able to plug in two drives at
once and you can copy and move your
games & downloads to the drives
microsoft says this is a great way to
bring your games or content to a
friend's house and start playing you'll
still need to log into xbox lab to
verify that you purchase the games but
you won't need to redownload the games
or DLC for comparison the playstation 4
does not allow external storage but it
does allow you to swap out their
internal 500 gigabyte hard drive with a
new one the update coming in june also
introduces the option to use your real
name to identify yourself this is an
optional feature and if you do decide to
use your real name you can choose who
can see it and who cannot besides a slew
of features and functionality being
added to the second screen smart glass
app this update will also allow popular
apps such as Netflix to be used without
an active xbox live subscription for
even more xbox news be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot com